各位投资者,大家晚上好。今天开的电话会议,主要还是应一些我们的投资者,包括一些分析师朋友,应他们的要求,针对今天整个市场以及包括公司股价,深度的市场的一些传闻,包括公司的一些经营情况,包括行业情况,各方面作出回应。
所以说,我也是代表公司管理层,召开今晚的电话会议。首先我想表达的是,针对今天市场的一些传闻,公司的回应。
就是,今天大家也看到,市场广泛的传言说是,咱们这个行业的1.6T光模块的价格,那么一度,就是大家看到的什么,叫做600美金,甚至有些说更低。
当然也有些认为说是,因为新进入的一些,咱们这个行业的一些友商,他们爆出了一些激进的价格。
那么,我想回应的是,第一个呢,我们公司的1.6T的价格,针对明年的价格,那么肯定是远高于这个价格的,不可能是这么低的价格。
而不是大家想象的,这个行业,恶性竞争,是吧,跟其他行业一样的,大家都在恶性竞争,我想不存在这个情况。
其次呢,我们也了解到,我们的友商也没有这么低的价格,好吧,所以说,这个完全就是一些传闻,跟事实不符,没有大家想象的这个行业。
我在上次的大会里面也提到过,我们这个行业,总体会比较健康的,那么目前的存在的情况就是,需求非常旺盛,那么原材料也非常的这个缺,那么同时呢,对1.6T的交付,现在是非常稀缺的,并不是像大家想象的,好像各家都能够大规模的交付1.6T,所以说,针对今年,下半年到,
明年的1.6T,我相信,能够交付的,仍然是少数的炒仓,这是第一点。第二个,价格也没有,市场传的那么离谱,我可以,我只能用离谱这两个事来形容,那么也不存在所谓的,
我看到上面常常说,公司的毛利和业绩受到影响,我们在此前的7月12号的电话会议上,也强调了,公司的这个价格是有竞争力的,但同时呢,公司的这个价格也是,能够让公司的毛利和,公司的各方面的收入,各方面保持稳定的,不存在市场所传门的那样,
我想表达的是,因为,这个昨天晚上的,这个美股,是吧,大家看到,这个下跌,我们的同行,这个股票下跌,那么,以及包括其他行业,跟这个AI相关的行业,
这些股票下跌,然后呢,时常也产生了非常悲观的情绪,认为,是不是因为资本开支不可持续,或者说,这种发展模式不是很好,等等,那么有各种,这些观点吧,但是呢,我们只能从,咱们关门块这个行业,这个角度,以及我们观察到的,我们的客户,我们下游的这些,
CSP客户也好,或者其他的这些,呃,设备商客户等等,呃,他们目前的,一个需求情况,我可以,呃,分享给大家,呃,目前,呃,我也非常明确,告诉大家,呃,那么,就是,我们的客户,呃,
呃,几乎所有的客户已经把这个,这个都是已经下了,呃,而且,有些客户已经把2027年的订单也下了,呃,呃,那么,已经不是指引了,是订单,呃,呃,那么,我在7月12号的会议上也提到了,就是,
他已经是,每个月的,一些交付量,呃,要交多少,这些都已经严格规定了,呃,所以说,呃,大家不用去担心说,
2027年,呃,还看不清楚,2027年非常清楚,而且需求是,相比2026年,呃,不管是800G,1.6T,是吧,呃,以及包括,呃,还会出现一些,呃,
呃,2.4期,或者是,NPO等等这些,新的产品,呃,那么,这些都是,呃,确定性比较强的,呃,而且增长的幅度也蛮大的,呃,特别是800G,1.6T,呃,这是,呃,第一个想表达,第二个呢,呃,
我们的一些还有学生的重点客户，他们已经给了我们《2028年》的新的产品具体的指引，也是非常强劲的，进入也非常大，
如果说我们这些大客户资本开支不可持续，他们没有必要告诉你《2028年》的需求，这就是一个很简单的逻辑,对吧?
大家在怀疑我们的大客户资本开支不可持续的时候,那我是明确告诉你,他们明确告诉我们《2028年》的需求，而且采购金额，这是新产品的采购金额非常大。
我们在前次，可能上次教练没有提到这么详细的这个数字，但我现在可以告诉大家,非常大,这是一个进而发言。
这是关于需求方面，说我想重点证明的两点，第一个是关于明年的报价，很多市场传闻是严重不俗实，第二点,关于明年的需求，甚至包括部分客户已经给了《2028年》的指引。
我认为客户的资本开支是持续的，而且他们是看好这个行李,愿意投入。
好吧,我大概抽到这两点，其他的欢迎请问,针对于大家，所有的这些担忧，大家可以坦诚的这个经济交友。
好,谢谢大家。
感谢明的真相,下面进入互动交流环节,欢迎各位投资者举出语言或发送文字提问。
大家好,如需提问,电话端的参会者,请向话机上的新号件再按数字一。
网络端的参会者,您可以在直播间互动区域内文字提问。
或点击旁边的举手按钮,申请语音提问。
谢谢。
大家好,如需提问,电话端的参会者,请向话机上的新号件再按数字一。
网络端的参会者,您可以在直播间互动区域内文字提问。
或点击旁边的举手按钮,申请语音提问。
谢谢。
下面有请电话伟号,5423的参会者进行提问。
请您有先提供您的姓名和机构名,请发言,谢谢。
喂,秦总好,我是扎克冰错,我有两个问题。
有一部分客户也给了新产品的指引,我想请教一下,新产品是Scale Out，还是Scale Up，的，如果是Scale Up，的话,Scale Out，有没有一些指引?谢谢。
就是我们说的新产品,其实主要就是,第一个就是针对2028年2.4T,第二个就是针对2028年的NPO，还有XPO,这些都是对于我们来说,以及对行业来说,都是非常新的产品。
那么,我想说明的是,不管是这个NPO，还是2.4T,这个量都是比较大的,但是呢,因为针对了具体的路面客户,我们不方便去把它的具体数量回机采购金额告诉大家,那么我只能用精性的语言告诉大家,这个量是比较大的,他们仍然在去加这部分的采购。
然后第二个问题是想请教一下,明年因为NPO开始上亮了,
然后下部光源这边我们物料的爱情,想跟你起药一下。
其实不仅仅都是光屏片,还有其他的电信店也好,还有PTV,
以及包括一些微信件,包括电动感等等这些都有。
那么这方面我们都在全部署我们的采购计划,
因为我们也看到下游强劲的需求,
所以说公司也在提前的进行这方面的准备。
那么这些都是以前在前次电话会上也来到明确讲的,
包括跟我们的现有供应商签订长鞋,
那么希望否定它未来几年的新扩出来产能。
第二个就是我们也会扩充新的供应商,保证进一步的供应。
第三个就是通过预付款,甚至通过一些对一些核心供应商的股权投资的方式,是吧?
这些是我们的进一步加强跟他们之间的保定。
这些错误都是非常有效的。
现在,我们的工厂商很多也受到了激励,
他们也愿意积极地活产。
所以说,我们会看到我们的物料会逐渐地改善。
在后期提点,包括今年下半年,麻烦哪一位投资者静静一下,那么我们也可以看到今年下半年,我们的无聊就会有接着性的改善。这样的话,我们今年下半年预计的出货量,各方面都会明显的好转。好吧,好,先说到这。
好,谢谢您。
好的,感谢您的简单。
欢迎各位投资者举手与互动或发送文字提问。
大家好,如需提问,
电话端的参会者,
请向话题上的新号件再按数字一。
网络端的参会者,
您可以在直播间互动区域内文字提问。
货点机旁边的举手按钮申请语音提问。
谢谢。
大家好,如需提问,
电话端的参会者,
请向话题上的新号件再按数字一。
网络端的参会者,
您可以在直播间互动区域内文字提问。
货点机旁边的举手按钮申请语音提问。
谢谢。
顺利有请电话委号1509的参会者进行提问。
请有请提供您的姓名跟机构名,
请发言,谢谢。
你好,
而军总你好,
我是来自国金证券的计算机分析师顺元号,
非常感谢您在这个时间点,
还能出来给大家去稳定军心。
我想请教您两个问题,
第一个就是已经开始谈到关于价格的问题。
我想再拆细点,
比如我们看到明年的价格,
比如说1.6T也好,
它如果存在一定的一个调整的话,
它背后的原因主要是跟客户在
整个沟通过程当中,
商量的一个粘匠的一个基本情况,
还是说会因为竞争了家具造成的价格的一个调整。
所以这一点想请教您拆解背后的一个逻辑。
第二个的话也是想再追问一下,
就是市场其实会比较担心后续的一个竞争格局的变化,
其实我记得您在上一次的电话会里面,
也给大家交流过这个情况,
但能不能想起您在帮大家拆解,
还是我们如何去把握后续整个市场进入,
进入这个三道里面的一个竞争的地位,
因为有很多新的友商都在讲,
他们进来可能会搞定一些光芯片后续的情况,
但是我们该如何去把握这个市场的一个供需的一个情况,
以及潜在的竞争的这种进来,
对整个竞争格局的影响,
那还关于这两个话题下,
那请进一步来给大家分享一下,谢谢。
好的。
关于你第一个问题,
我想我是这么看的,
就是这个行业,
其实每年咱们以往的情况,
确实每年都有架杂连降,
有架杂连降,
但是这个也不是什么新宣事,
真的要看每一年的供需关系,
是吧,供需的这个情况,
因为特别是进入到2025年到2026年这个阶段,
大家也看到需求增长得非常迅猛,
同时物料也变得非常紧张,
那么每一家公共工理商都会根据自身的成本情况,
包括你的产品的技术情况,
以及在客户这边取得的一些份额等等,
那么报出合理的价格,
那么至少我们观察目前的这些报价,
还是比较健康的,
也没有大家为了恶意去争夺份额,
去报非常低的价格,
更不存在大家传言的那样,
这个动辄就是百分之几十的降负,
这些我觉得非常夸张,
也根本不符合现实的情况,
如果确实有的话,
那也不是主流的供应商所做的事情,
那么还有呢就是我想说明的是,
那么就是我们的这些产品里边,
其实1.6T也分很多种,是吧,
包括EML版本,
硅光版本,
那么还有500米距离的DR系列的,
也有包括2公里,
甚至更长距离的,
这些FR,或者是LR,等等,
那么甚至还有多么的更短距的,
其实这些价格肯定是都不一样,
是吧,根据它的传输距离的长短,
那么多么的价格肯定是更便宜,
那么,
更多的价格和风距离也更强,价格会越来越贵。
我们应该如何浓统的说,这是多少钱呢?
还是要根据自身的情况,有些有商他们在某些型号取得,可能包的价格是这个价格,
但是还有一些更强距离的价格,包的价格更贵,
那么一页没有版本,比本轨光本甚至可能包的还要贵一些。
所以说不同的型号、不同的客户等等
它的价格肯定是不一样的
对吧
那么如果说从这个加权平均
是吧
ASP这个价格来看的话
我认为这个价格
就是刚才大家提到
就是他问这个价格是非常离谱的价格
好吗
我想表达一下
那么第二个呢
就是关于这个供应格局
供应格局
那么现在确实
因为行业需求非常旺盛
那么我们的大客户
为了保障他的供应
他们会在原有的三家或者是两家技术上
他们会增加
那么一两家供应商
确实有这种情况
部分的客户确实存在这种情况
也有客户没有增加
仍然保持现状都有
那么增加进来的
它主要是极限在现有的一些
特定的一些客户那里
确实增加供应商
但不代表说整体的这个行业
好像所有的客户
都增加了很多供应商
这个规则仍然是原有的
那么我以前给大家讲过
就是光模块行业
它的不同厂家之间的光模块
它是有互通性的
它是要一具有技术兼容的
就是说它不同的厂家的品牌的
光模块会在同一个水中硬里面
混叉使用
所以说必须要相互互通才行
那个互通测试
技术的测试
必须要由客户
盆出它的技术资源
研发资源这些
来进行测试
这个是非常消耗资源的
和时间经历的
所以说很多客户
它其实更愿意找三家固定的供应商
长期合作
那么如果是确实
因为供应缺口比较大
那么他们可能导入
新年期供应商进来
但是这个量也是非常有钱的
并不像大家想象的
好像每一家都是开放
整个市场
所有的光模块商都可以自由进出
这个行业格局还没有插到那个程度
总体来说我还是非常不错的
这是第一个
第二点就是说
现在新进来的有商
很多其实更多的是
集中在800G的供应商面
因为确实是因为800G的供应量非常大
就是需求量非常大
导致了客户增加了一些新的供应商
那么1.6T的话
它的量也会变大
但是1.6T的门槛会更高
那么首先要通过客户的认证
测试
包括整个导入的过程
实际上时间是比较长的
至少我们没有看到1.6T
当然去供应商是变得非常多的
这是第一个
而且现在大家可以看到
1.6T的产业的导入的情况
它也是投入的客户率先开始用
今年就开始用
是吧
今天变得很大
但是明年的量会更大
绝大部分的1.6T的需求
仍然是集中投入了几个大的客户
而投入了大的客户那边的1.6T的供应商
基本上还是有限的
并不像大家想的
好像很多进来了
都在争夺1.6T的份额非常混乱
我想格局没有查到这个程度
那么我们作为行业的1.6T的
率先的这个技术市场的供应商
我们确实在这个方面
取得了非常显著的竞争优势
几个核心的大核心,我们都是拿到了不错的证额,非常具有竞争力,而且价格也非常好,这我想表达,那么还有呢,就是在更高端的,更高速率的一些产品,比如说2.4T,上面需要用到一些更高端的一些技术,包括【技术名听不清】,也包括这个硅光,包括薄膜铌酸锂等等,那么这块的话,目前来说,
在整个行业里边,只有非常少数的,这个供应商,能够去支持客户,去提供这样的,这种高端的这种产品,再比如说,NPO,那么它对硅光芯片,对电信片,以及对一些新型工装等等,它是要求非常高的,那这块的话,目前能够参与到这里边的,也是数量非常少的,其实你可以看到整个行业,它在不断的快速迭代,
高退,这种高带宽,高速率,这些产品,甚至从ScaleOut到ScaleUp到ScaleOff,几个不同的应用场景,
而这些，它的市场，目前来说我们看到的就是
这个行业在这个方面的竞争格局是非常有限的，不是大家想象的很多都可以进去。
客户的要求高度定时，对于产品的技术要求，性能各方面的要求非常高，
它必须是要求这些具备，现有技术能力的，才能达到这个要求，可以成为供应商。
所以在这里边我觉得这个供应格局并不是让大家想象的变得更差，而是这个行业技术含量非常高，不断的技术曲线变得越来越有效。
所以说这样的话我们的整个，对于虚放来说,我们的整个在未来几年的发展,我认为我们的机会行业会变得更多，而不是变得更窄。
我想解释第二个问题,请提下。
好,非常感谢军总的回答。那我这边没有别的问题,感谢。
感谢令到的介绍。
声明游戏电话伟号8606的财慧者进行提问。
请您有请提供您的姓名和新购买,请发言。谢谢。
军总,您好,我是中信里洋的分析师,通尼扎。
我想问一下您刚才提到的就是我们对这个2027年的这个订单,现在有了更高的能限度。
不知道对我们2027年公司在这种比较强的需求还有很多新产品的情况下,咱们对这个毛利率或者淨利率大概有没有方向性的展望?谢谢。
好的,首先我们也看到公司的这个钱的订单,从这个需求量到价格各方面我觉得都是非常不错的。
这是我们目前的情况,因为确实现在整个行业的需求非常旺盛,在所这个物料的紧缺,这些呢也就是带来了些困难。
所以说在这种情况下,我相信我们行业的各个供应商的报价都是比较谨慎的。
那么大家对这个报价一个是比较谨慎,第二个呢就是也要看一些你的冻免弹琴,在这里面的一个份额等等。
所以说现在说我觉得我们的毛利,我们是非常有信心保持稳定的。
那么在2027年的新产品开始上量的时候,我们有信心,就是这些新产品的毛利,肯定是远高于目前的这些现有成量的这些产品。
所以说呢,它的这个快速的上量能够有效地拉动我们的毛利的增长。
因此我们预判我们在未来当我们的公司进入到一些新的应用市场,比如说ScaleUp,这里面光连接解决方案。
那么凭借我们的技术能力,已经我们这个在行业里面的一些领先的一些这个就是领先的这些速度和升位。
那我想我们是有能力做的把这个产品更好的交付给客户,取得很好的这个毛利。
这些都是有能力进步的提升我们的整体的这个毛利率的。
好的,清楚了。谢谢郡总。
感谢令到的检查。欢迎各位投资者进行语音提问或文字提问。
大家好,如需提问,电话端的参会者,请先按画机上的新号件再按数字一。
网络端的参会者,您可以在直播间互动区域内文字提问,或点击旁边的举手按钮,申请语音提问。
谢谢。
下面有请电话委号0588的参会者请提问。
请先提供您的姓名跟姬公名,请发言,谢谢。
今天我们也看到了这个市场的传言,我们也是觉得,我们还要有点心,
我们也会互动联系的一个传言的社会订阅,
我们也会调一下一下,您的名字和您的名字,您可以在下面提问。
谢谢。
呃,就是今天我们也看到了这个市场的传言
我们也是觉得
嗯,这个一旦都起有这么多的信号
从sr到
这个很荒谬,那我想问两个,我觉得在对明年的整个增量很,我自己很关心的问题,一个就是大家一直在讨论Scale Up。
那我们也会注意到像NVL、华为的方案里面在柜内
喂?你这边听不到你的声音了。
请这位投资者调试设备稍后介入。欢迎各位投资者举手语音提问。
我发送文字提问，晓明有请电话维号6237的才会者进行提问。请您优先提供您的姓名跟机构名,请发言,谢谢。
哎,君总好,我是中金的分析师李诗文,其实我想问的问题我听下来跟前面那个张老师问的应该差不多,就是您今天也讲到二八。
我们在CSP客户订单这边看到的能见度,我觉得这个对于市场信心的提振非常重要,就是现在我们在想的一个问题,也是其实在光,在数据中心。
投资占比的这个维度上来讲,您看可不会帮我们再多做一些分享,就包括未来SIL的一些大客户他潜在的方案当中看到的一些新型的。
这种产品形态,以及在Scale Up 网络当中增量的使用,因为这可能也意味着即使在28年大家对资本开支的增速有一些预期的
但是光在整体的占比上的提升仍然是很快的
所以其实从整个行业的角度上来讲也是有不可忽视的这种行业赛道的这个alpha存在的
对 就想从这个角度看客户请您再帮忙做一下分享
好的 对 就关于这个光模块或者整个光连接的产品
在整个大客户的资本开支的这个占比
我认为是在不断的提升的
而且提升的速度真的加快
主要原因是大家可以看到在这个以往的这个光模块
它在整个我们的CSP客户的资本开支里面
我们
不超过它的这本开支的5个百分点
那么这是以往
特别是在这个传统的互联网时代
云术中心时代
那么这个比例是相对比较低的
那么之所以这么高呢
我想其实现在也在逐渐的变高
主要原因呢是第一个呢
就是产品的技术接待也在加快
其实你可以看到从2023年开始
我们的重点客户开始使用800G
到今年2026年开始
8Pi的部殊167
那么在后面
大家会看到还有更高数率的这些产品
【前一速率听不清】或者3.2T
这些产品都会有了
在2027年到2028年
这个阻截的推出
那么还会有这个
更高带宽的这个
Scale Up的供联阶产品
NPO或者CPO【低置信】等等
那么包括3.2T、6.4T
甚至12.8T
以及包括在多个属于中心之间的互联
远区之间的互联
【DCI相关产品名听不清】的产品
这个量也会变得非常大
所以说这些其实都是代表的这个
光连接产品
我们其实把统筹为光连接产品
它在整个CAPEX里面的这个占比
比例会进步的提升
因为他们的价格
其实是大家看我们的价格曲线
是在不断地往上走的
而不是往下
这是这个行业表现成的一方面
就是第一个技术迭代非常快
第二个它的这个平均的这个价格
ASP是在不断地往上走的
因为价格越来越高端
高的原因是因为它的技术含量
含尽量的不能提升
带款也在不能提
所以说它整体的这个BOM成本
包括能够参与到里边的
这个供应商其实是
不是变得更多而是变得越来越
整个行业的
为什么我一直说这个行业的
这个整体的格局是表现成的
而不是大家想象的
我现在好像变得非常的荣棘
大家一直在恶性的竞争
一直在降价
并不是大家想象的这样子
我非常的反对
就是一些观点认为
我们是跟其他的一些
2021年的阶段的行业
或者是跟甚至可能像那一笔
认为这个行业是没有技术含量的
是一个组装行业等等
就是这些言论
那么我们现在可以说,我们就是非常明确的告诉你,这个行业是在健康的增长,为什么呢?就是基于整个行业对带宽的需求,对技术的要求,以及对整体行业的应用场景的增加,光连接的应用在除了原型的交换机之间的互联,现在也用到包括Scale Up里面的服务器,内存,网卡等等。
很多应用场景都需要原型同连接的方向,都很多现在逐渐用光的替代,这会在2027到2028年之间的会逐渐的显现出来,同时我们也会看到在一些更长距离的一些连接,我们说的圆区之间的互联,DCI互联,还有楼宇之间等等,那么这里面有大量的也有光连接的应用场景,而且带宽也在提升。
未来也会是光连接的用场景。所以说它的整个体的技术还在不断地提升。所以说技能格局也会，我们认为是一直在向好的。因为能够全面掌握所有的这些尖端的技术,包括硅光芯片技术,包括薄膜铌酸锂技术,包括【技术名听不清】这些技术,也包括一些先进封装技术等等。那么这些技术的话,含力量是越来越高。不是大家想象的,这是个
大众化的技术,或者是标准品的技术。不是这样的。好,谢谢，
下面有请电话伟号，
0588的开会者进行提问，
请您有先提供您的姓名，跟机共名，
请翻言，
谢谢
您好，刚才不好意思，我的网位有点问题，我是国内民生的张宁，
我想问一个问题，上次提到过800G的需求在上升，
那么1.6T现在也是需求不错的，
我想问一下，在800G的增长，在800G里面，
有没有一定比例的单波200G的这种800G，
这一类的800G的产品，是否是它的毛利率，和门槛，
因为是以单波200G为基础的，那门槛会更高，然后营质比会更好，
就是跟1.6T基本上有效，我觉得有没有这一部分的需求在里面，
确实有单波200G的这种产品规格，这个技术还量会更高，
但是基于单波200G的这种技术，用在800G上面，相对于四成200G
而且其他的很多客户，用的是8通路，就是8成单波100G
这一块的话，是现在量比较大的，但是确实也有四成200G
四成200G的，然后把它再扩充的话，就变成了8成200G
就是一种T，就是单波200G技术其实已在日需成熟，而且这个出货量，像我们今天已经出了很多产品
它的价格，各方面，毛利，各方面都肯定是显著好于8成100G的
好，那么我觉得我们看未来，就是我们今年整个市场一直在关注我们或者整体预期
那可能SKOP就是最重要的一个量了，这里面有两个就是我们去以NV的这个利益的决定
那么比如576，那么第二层，也就是柜子和柜子之间的SKOP去用NPO的产品是有一致预期的
那么在机柜内部，就是目前你们比同软覆盖的这部分产品
就是在一个柜子内的SKOP和SV之前这个部分的同软，从2017年28年单波200G
速度的这个角度您看，这个部分有没有一个用光去替代同软的这种确定趋势和节点存在的
我觉得对整个增量的判断是一个很重要的点，这成交印象
您指的是在柜内，对,柜内的SKOP是在这一时间，对,对
目前还没有看到这样的这么快的替代，目前没有，最后可能还需要更长的时间
对,了解,那麽第三个就是您刚才提到过的就是我们现在的800G、1.6T
我们也相信这是一个非常技术含量的行业，更不要说咱们公司在上游的一些pick这一端的竞争优势吧
那肯定是在高科技的行业里,我们更是一个更加有高科技固执的公司
这个我也多次也会把这个观念,那么我们想问就是随着国内的800G,这些需求的兴趣
甚至国内一些一等又去的学习,那么国内市场
我们的国内市场有没有一些突然的规划,以及这个部分的利润会不会逐渐的向海外的高代成品
去基于这个供给的关系,去逐渐的去贴近,这也是一个我们觉得有增长空占的逻辑
国内市场确实也在快速发展,我想我们
这几年从去年到现在,国内的对AI数据中心的建设和需求，光连接产品的需求都在提升。
那么也会随着跟客户的建设规划相匹配。
所以我们会看到未来几年,不管是现有的800-400G,包括未来的UTO,包括NPO,也会出现国内市场。
整体的价格区间,ASP也是在往上走的。
我相信整个行业还是在于健康的发展。
如果要跟海外市场价格提进,国内的精准格局和海外经济格局还是有差异的。
这块儿的话,我觉得有这种价格的差异是很正常的。
我最后一个问题,就是问一下,您刚才说的技术曲线跟SWC的问题。
我自己看过去两年,过去几年里面,我们基本上是单波50,单波100,单波200。
虽然我们也把通道割了8,但是曲线还在沿着上游的核心去衍生的。
但是现在,从今天公众会我们看到,从单波从8通道200G到我们甚至看到32通道的差异,
然后也有很多人员超过8通道的,16通道的NPO,然后整个的新道的间隔也越来越紧密。
从这个角度,我看咱们公司在上游的一些布局,是不是让公司在更加抖撬的曲线里面,
都掌握了比之前的技术接待过程中更强的主动性来保证公司以后更强的竞争力,
以及说这种对心理丰富的依赖,是不是也会对我们有些新的挑战。
这就是我自己觉得26年下半年的二纪年28年吧,有个很重要的点。
不知道在这个点上去,放手说明给我们再解读一下。
对,反正你的问题我可能没法一一的回应,但是我想说的是,
我们正在逐渐地成长了一个平台性的公司,那么拥有很多或者正在预言或者是正在发展一些很多核心的技术,
这个核心的技术都会对我们整体这个行业里面所需要的一些,这是我们前面提到的,
这是谁的AI发展,那么更高的带宽,更低的功耗,以及更低的实验等等,
按照这几个核心的技术要求,那么我们都在按照这些方面去准备。
那么所以说公司,前面其实我在前面的问题里面已经列举了很多我们的一些核心技术,
这些技术都对我们目前推出下一代新的产品,更高数的产品,
以及包括甚至用于这个FERAP,这个用于抗几的这些机柜之间的互联,
或者甚至包括未来到机柜内等等,这些其他非常关键的作用。
我想这些该拥有的技术我们一定都会逐渐开发出来,
所以这也是公司的一个技术方面的一个强大的自信。
谢谢您,总。这样我们最后一定会落到一个领天行业的估值上来,
认可公司的这种价值的。感谢您,感谢。我就是这些问题。
感谢另一位接答。下面有请调查委号2089的财汇者进行提问,
请您有钱提供您的姓名跟机构名,请发言。谢谢。
您好,我是田园基金博士,
想跟你请教一下,有些之前的朋友也提到咱们会调 up 这个量,
想请教一下,在我现在看到的2027年的需求里面,
您觉得在调 up 里面的这个需求占地大概估下来可能有多大?
但是我没办法去给你量化了,因为我只能这么跟你说吧,在2027年下半年开始,目前看到我们至少看到了两个行业里边非常具有影响力的客户开始批量的采购NPO的产品,那么这个产品的量是逐渐上量的,那么真正的更大规模的上量是在2028年。
好吧,这是第一点想表达的。第二点想表达的是,还有更多的一些CSP客户，大模型公司客户，包括New Cloud客户，他们对NPO方案非常感兴趣,也会在今年到明年这个阶段,正在陆续的导入这些产品,我们日然坚信NPO会成为未来在光联界方面的一个非常主流的产品。
所以说它的放量应该是,就是一个像1.6T,今年2026年开始正式的放量,我相信NPO也是这样,它也是有这么一个分阶段的一个过程,刚开始有头部的一些行业有影响的公司,开始率先的导入NPO,然后后面更多的一些客户会跟进,那么成为一个在scale up这个领域里边的一个主流方案。
好,明白了,就带你出问题。
明白,谢谢郡总。
可能再请教一下,就是说因为原来大家讲的这个根据CSP的组网架构,
可能这个GPU跟这个光模块1比3甚至1比4的这个比例,
我们现在看到这个组网架,从组网架构的结构来看的话,
这个比例是有在继续上升吗?
因为看到明年的整个的GPU或者ACC的出乎量看起来,
就是没有那么的大,或者它有一个很高的增长,
但是要匹配一个两亿支光模块的量的话,
看起来跟原来这个1比3、1比4的对应关系没有那么的明确,
是说这个本身的组网架构的对应关系也在往上涨,
然后又有一些NPO的量。
对的,我觉得我们跟客户沟通过的关系,
就是不少的客户就告诉我们他们的这个就是,
这些对应关系的比例是在提升的。
可能大家还说听到在原先的1比3这个认知里边,
但实际上从2025年开始,
那么包括现在2026年,
大家看到的800G、1.6T,这个快速的增长,
那么包括2027年，这个，在这么大技术的情况下，仍然是，这个，更快的增长，这些其实都预示了，整体的这个，在Scale Out，网络里边，这些光模块，对应AI芯片的比例是在，近有的增长的，至少，是翻了一倍，甚至翻了更多，主要原因，还是因为整个这个，AI集群，的规模变大，它其实需要承载更多的，晶，
到这个，柜间【听不清】以及到，从这个，服务器机柜，到这个，扩展网络，它需要，这个规模变得更大，所以说，它的连接的，应用场景变多了，所以需要的光模块数量也变多了，所以说网络架构变大了，
好,最后可能想请教一下,
就是因为我们其实是行业里面比较能看到比较好的一个全局的需求,
可能27年,
想理解一下我们这个2027年的看到这个订单量,
这个是CSP它会直接告诉我们一个他们需求的总量,
还是说是我们根据我们拿到的订单量,
只要反推一个份额,得到一个市场的总量规模的。
对,有些客户是机会告诉我们他的需求总量,
也会告诉我们的份额,
但也有一些客户他是背靠背的,
他是会告诉我们的份额,
就是给我们的量是多少,是吧?
然后我们在根据以往的这个,
我们在你的大概份额,
我们能够反推他懂的需求,
反正这是不同的情况吧,
有一客户可能他会给我们的信息会更多一起。
明白了,好,多谢军长,
我就这些问题,
也是预处公司港股上市长宏,
谢谢。
好,谢谢你。
感谢各位投资者的提问以及领导的分享,
今天的会议也交流非常充分,
请问领导还有需要总结或者补充的吗?
我这边没有更多的这个观点,
就是特别想给大家说,
就是越是在这个时候,
其实更能看出整个行业,
就是通过交流,
大家可以看出这个行业到底是健康还是不健康,
所以竞争格局是向好还是进步的恶化,是吧?
我觉得通过充分的沟通交流,
大家可以对这些能够提升,
大家对这个行业的判断,
这是第一点。
第二个呢,
我也希望当市场有这种,
朝鲜的时候也希望大家主动的跟我进行交流,
进行这个了解,是吧?
我们也很愿意通过这种电话会议,
或者通过其他的,
甚至大家可以直接的联系我,
都可以了解到真实的情况。
我们也,
这些人也愿意保留一些行业和公司的生殖情况,避免市场传言的误导。
至于整个目前人起的市场行情,大家可能情绪上不要担忧,或者甚至恐慌,我觉得这些都是暂时的,
因为我坚信我们这个行业仍然是健康的,而且在持发展,客户的日本孩子也是持续的。
这就是我自己表达的观点。
谢谢大家,也谢谢你们的时间,今晚这么晚的成交会议。
好,那就先这样。
感谢大家参加本次会议。会议到此结束。祝大家生活愉快,再见。